or jacques delors bon soin alors j'ai vu
que vous écoutiez avec attention la
musique du générique de cette émission
je vous posais une question vous êtes un
mélomane averti est-ce que vous avez
reconnu cette musique je peux me tromper
mais je crois que c'est live and let die
des beatles
celle de paul mccartney parfait que
c'est une bonne réponse à une première
question
maintenant passons passons aux choses
aux choses plus graves
il y aura il y aura un an demain que
vous êtes entré dans le gouvernement de
pierre mauroy avec le poste qui est
toujours le vôtre aujourd'hui de
ministre de l'économie et des finances
alors le 21 mai dernier
tout le monde s'accordait à dire que
vous acceptiez là un poste important et
vos adversaires politiques vous
attendez-vous la gauche au virage de
l'économie on pensait que la gauche ne
saurait pas gérer les affaires de la
france si vos partisans au contraire on
attendait tous de vous on attendait la
justice le dialogue la solidarité où
vous voyez déjà pourfendre les
inégalités le chômage la vie chère
réformer la fiscalité dans un sens plus
juste et les questions bien entendu
qu'on vous posera tondre autour d'eux
qu'avez-vous fait le seul ministre de
cette première année de pouvoir alors
vous nous direz aussi où vous souhaitez
conduire la france et les français alors
pour vous interroger ce soir les
téléspectateurs dans tête de ils peuvent
dès maintenant appelée svp 11/11 c'est à
dire pour ceux d'entre eux qui n'ont pas
de l'être sur leurs cadrans 787 11-11
précédé si vous appelle de province du
16 et du 1 16
un 787 11 11
mais avant de donner la parole aux
téléspectateurs à la fin de cette
émission vous allez monsieur le ministre
et vous le savez quand vous savez que
c'est la règle du jeu vous allez passer
trois mauvais quart d'heure avec trois
journalistes successifs dont je vous ai
jusqu'à présent caché les noms alors
l'heure est venue de découvrir ensemble
les noms de ceux du premier d'entre eux
est à vous de tirer au sort alors je
vous dis je réalise numéro un
journaliste numéro 2 ou journalistes
numéro 3 vous choisissez de 2 alors deux
je consulte ma liste et 2 noël copains
d'antenne 2
alors nul copains noël copains d'antenne
2 et le chronomètre des marques
chronomètre
c'est parti pour 15 minutes monsieur le
ministre une question qui n'est pas
original parce que c'est celle que toute
la presse se pose est est ce matin et on
annonce un indice des prix de 1,1 à 1,2
au mois d'avril avec cet indice la
pouvez vous tenir votre pari votre pari
d'arriver à 10% d'appelation à la fin de
l'année oui je le pense bien que
j'aurais espéré 1,1 pour le mois d'avril
mais pour expliquer cela peut-être
pourrions-nous revenir un peu en arrière
en juin dernier
que faire il y avait trois solutions
premièrement bloquer les prix c'est la
solution la plus populaire mais
l'expérience a montré que l'on ne savez
jamais comment en sortir
et puis bloquer les prix au moment où
nous voulions relancer l'expansion c'est
un peu comme si vous accédez riez
effrénée en même temps sur une voiture
ça donne une belle embardée ou plutôt ça
donne d'étouffement
deuxième solution pratique et une purge
c'est à dire accepter d'avoir deux
millions et demi de chômeurs à la fin de
1982 ce n'était pas possible non
seulement parce que la gauche n'avait
pas été élu pour accroître le nombre des
chômeurs mais surtout parce que le
chômage minent notre société
son goût du travail ses forces son
courage sa capacité de survie
par conséquent il n'était pas question
de purger d'ailleurs avant nous pendant
cinquante six mois raymond barre avait
utilisé ce que j'appellerais une semi
purge et le résultat était là huit cent
mille chômeurs de plus 150 6 mois et
lorsque nous sommes arrivés un taux
d'inflation de 15% alors devant cela
étant humble devant les faits il nous a
semblé que le mieux était de s'attaquer
à la cause la plus évidente de la maaf
nation c'est-à-dire l'intoxication
on s'habitue à vivre à 14 à 15 %
d'inflation et spécialistes discutent
sur les chiffres a dit que c'était moins
de 15% que c'était 13,8 ou même 13,2
écoutez j'ai confié à monsieur chatel
deux petits graphiques six années fait
se fait pas trop rétro anciennes
télévisions on peut peut-être les
montres et non pas restons reste on se
regarde on avait un graphique voulait
commenter voter mais voilà alors vous
avez l'année 1980 et vous voyez que
lorsque nous sommes arrivés au pouvoir
nous étions peut-être sur une planche
bande de 13 6 mai le gouvernement avait
retardé toutes les hausses de tarifs
mais moi je comprends rien je vois pas
quand vous êtes arrivé au pouvoir
là-dessus alors expliquez moi à quel
endroit de la courbe alors on va pas
casser le rythme de l'émission ça nous
arrivait au pouvoir un deux trois quatre
cinq là au moment où les où les prix
sont entre 13 et 14 mai que 1 donc nous
avons fait des hausses de tarifs publics
qui aurait dû être fait avant jeudi qu
donc que nous étions sur un rythme de
15% et ensuite après avoir soldé cette
affaire nous avons essayé de redescendre
progressivement puisque toutes les
autres méthodes ont échoué et donc au
quatrième trimestre nous étions sur un
rythme annuel de 12 % et à partir de là
nous avons pu dans le secteur public
qu'avant le secteur privé les choses
étaient partis proposé aux organisations
syndicales une nouvelle vanne salariale
qui nous permettait d'habitués une
partie des salariés à des hausses de
salaires en nominal moins forte mais
tout en leur garantissant comme aux
autres le pouvoir d'achat c'est par
conséquent sur ce rythme là je
m'attendais à une hausse des prix de 6,2
pour cent au premier semestre de 5,7
pour cent au second pour être précis et
pour le quatrième prime s ii et demi
c'est à dire multiplier par quatre les
10% dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
c'est ce que vous appelez dans une
formule que vous avez lancé cet après
midi jeux chez notre confrère le monde
la désinflation en douceur je voudrais
dire aux au directeur de l'actualité que
je n'ai pas donné d'interview au monde
comme cela arrive souvent un journaliste
m'a téléphoné pour me dire je fais un
article
par conséquent je ne commenterai pas ce
qui n'est pas un interview mais enfin
c'est bien ça la formule la désinflation
en douceur parce que je crois que c'est
la seule méthode qui permettait d'être
conciliable avec la lutte contre le
chômage
ce ministre est venu dit que je n'ai pas
accordé d'interview mais cette interview
mais quand même maintenant un prix mais
est-ce que vous la démonter et c'est
qu'on est maintenant dans le domaine
public non j'ai eu une conversation avec
monsieur vernholes mais il n'a jamais
dit qu'il ferait un interview et je lui
ai donné des éléments comme je vous en
donne à chacun d'entre vous lorsque vous
m'appelez parce qu'il m'a dit qu'il
faisait un artiste lauriers quand même
une phrase qui a retenu l'attention de
pas mal de lecteurs du monde
un gros travail à faire pour dégager
l'horizon des chefs d'entreprises dont
le moral a été très atteint en février
pour des raisons psychologiques et
politiques sur lesquels je préfère ne
pas insister
écoutez c'est l'heure de vérité
aujourd'hui c'est d'ailleurs de very
c'est pas l'heure des cancans par
conséquent je voudrais vous montrer mon
2ème graphique est resté sur les prix si
vous le permettez vous ne répondez pas
sur cette question des patrons et des
problèmes jugé logique qui sommes là
pour expliquer aux français le mieux
possible ce qui se passe alors si on
regarde le 2ème graphique on verra que
les prix ce n'est pas innocent ou le
gouvernement ni mise des finances n'est
pas l'enchanteur merlin regarder la
courbe duo folk est la plus haute ce
sont les prix agricoles
mais en contrepartie le revenu agricole
a cessé de se dégrader
le revenu agricole avait gagné 27% de
pouvoir d'achat de 70 73 il en avait
perdu 17% de 73 à 80 ans 80 il a été
maintenu grâce aux efforts que nous
avons faits en fin d'année maintenant le
revenu agricole sans même des aides
particulières et au dessus de la hausse
des prix puisque les prix à la
production monte de 14 et demi pour cent
alors si je suis si je souhaite que les
prix baissent je suis quand même heureux
que les agriculteurs retrouve par le
produit de leur travail
un revenu valable si vous regardez le
deuxième ce sont les services
nous avons appliqué des contrats de
modération avec avec la plupart des
professions je préfère ça aux blocages
des prix que je considère comme une
mesure absolument exceptionnel et vous
voyez que les services restent entre 10
et 11 que nous avions prévu un peu plus
parce qu'il ya les loyers ce mois ci
quant aux prix industriels
ils sont ils sont raisonnables autour de
10 compte tenu de la situation et compte
tenu des coûts de production voilà la
situation
donc les prix ce n'est pas remise
l'économie des finances qui d'un coup de
baguette magique peut les changer les
prix correspondent à l'économie à ce qui
se passe est pour l'instant un des
éléments positifs de cette hausse de
prix qui ralentit peu c'est quand même
le soutien du revenu des agriculteurs
donc pour résumer monsieur le ministre
pas de changement de votre politique
vaut continuer sur la même ligne
sur nous parlions tout à l'heure du
bilan de l'année et à propos de
changements avez-vous l'impression que
ce changement a profité à ceux qui sont
les plus défavorisés j'ai relu avant
cette émission je ne dirais pas vos
oeuvres complètes mais c'est tombé sur
une phrase vous disiez que vos
convictions vous placer d'emblée du côté
de ce que la société écrase ou ignorent
avez vous l'impression que ce qui était
écrasée ont été ignorés ou non par la
nouvelle société
oui la solidarité c'est un idéal mais
chacun peut avoir sa conception de
l'existence mais la solidarité c'est
également une nécessité
tout à l'heure nous parlerons de
l'effort tout à l'heure je l'espère nous
parlerons de la guerre économique dans
laquelle la france est plongée
mais pour que la france réagisse il faut
qu'elles soient plus solidaires il a
nous avons donc pris les mesures qui
comprend qui correspondait à nos
engagements pour les personnes
handicapées pour les personnes âgées
pour les familles pour les salariés aux
revenus modestes et en même temps
puisque nous avions dit que nous
réduirions la durée du travail nous
avons fait une première étape de façon à
bien montrer que nous n'avions pas été
élu sur un programme fantômes et sur un
programme réel ces mesures ayant été
prises réseaux rue de à double effet
premièrement j'ai beaucoup de français
ont aujourd'hui l'impression qu'ils sont
dans le même bateau que les autres qui
ne sont pas des délaissés et si
aujourd'hui on parle d'efforts et de
rigueur ils savent que ce n'est pas eux
qui mange tout le pain noir alors que
d'autres ont le pain blanc et en second
lieu cet effort de solidarité a permis
de soutenir la croissance économique
autrement dit nous étions l'avion une
voiture économique qui roulait à 50 à
l'heure actuellement elle roule la
soixante dix à l'heure certains disent
ah pourquoi pas 80 on expliquera ça tout
à l'heure mais celui que vous avez lancé
vous même le mot d'efforts n'ai pas été
surpris car c'est un donc je vais
utiliser je crois presque dès votre
domination
quelle différence entre l'effort quand
c'est jacques delors qui prononce le mot
et quand c'est raymond barre la
différence d'abord le style des hommes
et je
m'apparaît pas là dessus politiquement
je lis avec intérêt tout ce que dit
monsieur raymond barre et jean fauque
l'occasion de reparler de ce qu'il a dit
au tournoi là et chaque fois qu'il donne
un conseil au milieu des critiques je
pêche lafleur pour m'en servir
mais ce n'est pas ça qui était en cause
monsieur raymond barre à faisait le même
diagnostic que moi de la situation la
guerre économique la nécessité pour la
france de se muscler et de vin car ce
qui est en cause ce n'est pas
l'augmentation notre niveau de vie c'est
le maintien de notre niveau de vie d'ici
1990 ce qui est en cause ce n'est pas
une grande politique étrangère sans
s'occuper de l'intendance économique
c'est la capacité en 1990 de la france
de jouer un rôle dans le monde
que diraient nos enfants et nos petits
enfants si nous laissant aller où le
relais sur une france qui n'a plus son
mot à dire dans le monde vous employez
le volontiers le mot est fort ya un mot
qui n'est pas utilisée depuis un an qui
était utilisée avancer les mots
d'austérité est ce qu'un socialiste paie
un jour prononcé ce mot s'il convient de
le prononcer précisément c'est bien ça
la différence quand nous parlons
d'efforts et de rigueur et bien ce n'est
pas la même chose quand on en parle
après avoir soutenu le revenu des petits
agriculteurs pris les mesures de
solidarité dont je parlais tout à
l'heure et quand on les a pas prises il
fallait convaincre l'autre moitié de la
france celle qui avait été écartée
longtemps du pouvoir parce que ses
représentants n'y était pas qu elle
aussi elle faisait partie de la société
france et qui par conséquent demandé un
effort on le demandait à tous
c'est pourquoi ces mesures était un
préalable ce qui fait la différence
entre les deux politiques c'est
premièrement le fait que nous nous
adressons à tous les français nous leur
démontrons quand en s'adressant à eux
nous leur demandons à chacun un effort
proportionnel à ce qu'ils peuvent faire
justement une question que je lui posais
et c'est finalement depuis un an vous
voit-on que cette société est une
société socialiste prenons un exemple la
tva est ce que c'est très socialiste les
décisions qui viennent d'être prises sur
la tva et j'irai même plus loin sur un
plan personnel est ce que c'est bien
conforme aux convictions que vous avez
souvent exprimé sur la justice oui pour
appeler simplement que la tva est un
impôt sur la dépense et qui frappe tout
le monde sur sa dépense quel que soit le
niveau de richesse des gens on évalue en
gros que ça ferait une charge
supplémentaire de trois associés
laver et qui réduirait la part de la tva
oui mais la première la première
impératif c'est quand même de d'étudier
des réformes fiscales portant sur les
impôts directs avec beaucoup d'attention
par conséquent puisque nous avions à
financer des dépenses supplémentaires
consacrés exclusivement à
l'investissement et pourquoi
l'investissement depuis dix ans si on
met à parler fort dans le nucléaire et
dans les télécommunications
la france n'a pas assez investi la
france n'a pas assez cherché c'est comme
si vous vouliez aujourd'hui cueillir des
cerises alors vous n'aviez pas planter
des cerisiers notre parc d'équipements
notre outil de production a vieilli de
dix ans nous avons dix ans de retard sur
le japon 10 ans de retard sur les états
unis cinq ans de retard sur l'allemagne
par conséquent l'argent que nous non
dégagées là c'est pour l'investissement
et nous y ajouterons le concours des
bancs bien pour financer cela tout de
suite
compte tenu de ce qu'est la perception
fiscale des français aujourd'hui il nous
a paru plus équitable de prendre une
mesure sur la tva une mesure d'ailleurs
qui baissent certes un taux sur les
produits de première nécessité et qui
augmentent modérément le taux sur les
moyens on a quand même l'impression que
là le réalisme la haye peut emporter sur
les principes houleux mais vous savez
les faits sont têtus
alors le socialisme demeure notre
inspiration
nous ne perdons jamais de vue mais il
faut emprunter un sentier ardue et faire
attention où l'on marche
est ce parce que le sentier était ardue
et qu'il fallait faire attention ne
marche que le gouvernement était si
timide pour l'impôt sur la fortune
non c'est parce que il a pensé qu en
allant tout de suite plus loin il s'est
référé référer aux précédentes et u2
précédent le premier c'est en 1968
lorsque monsieur horten immunisés
finances s'est dit après la crise de 68
je vais augmenter l'impôt sur les
successions
ce fut un tollé général et pourtant ce
n'était pas une mauvaise idée quand on
compare le taux de l'impôt sur les
successions en france et dans les pays
étrangers il ya eu ensuite la femme le
fameux impôt sur les plus values
complètement ratée par le septennat
précédent par conséquent lorsque nous
avons décidé de faire l'impôt sur la
fortune parce que nous pensons que les
gens fait français peuvent contribuer à
la hauteur de
revenu est à la hauteur de leur fortune
à l'effort de balle nous avons fait
extrêmement attention de ne pas
pénaliser l'effort d'investissement et
aussi de ne pas pénaliser les chefs
d'entreprise qui depuis dix ans ayant
créé leur affaire personnelle en était
encore propriétaire pour une bonne
partie car nous aurions pénaliser ceux
qui pendant ces années très dures ont le
mieux oeuvré pour l'intérêt de leur
entreprise mais aussi de la france
ce ministre on a l'impression que si le
réalisme et vous pousse dans le domaine
économique au fiscale
un réalisme à une certaine de peut-être
timidité pour sortir de l'économie et on
remarque la même timidité dans d'autres
secteurs
un secteur que vous connaissez bien qui
est celui de la décentralisation
ça va peut-être un peu plus loin que ce
qu'avait fait chaban delmas à l'époque
vous étiez son conseiller m'a
l'impression que c'est un peu pareil cas
le gouvernement comme chaban ne va pas
aussi loin qu'il aurait voulu qu'à côté
vous avez vous allez n'avait pas encore
vu les textes sur les compétences et le
transfert des responsabilités
financières
quand vous voyez que ce sera vraiment
une révolution non je pense que la dea
qu'est ce que nous voulons faire
en plus de la gestion quotidienne que
vous appelez timide quand elle est
raisonnable et qu'elle tient compte des
faits ça c'est votre adjectif en banque
liche de cela qu avons nous fait nous
avons refait les fondations de la maison
france
l'extension du secteur public pour
justement mettre fin à cette stagnation
de l'investissement pour redonner du
muscat notre économie c'est fait la
décentralisation c'est la démocratie à
portée de la main
c'est le seul antidote contre la
bureaucratie le président de la
république quand il faisait sa campagne
électorale et qu'on lui préparer un
texte qui rajoutait toujours la
décentralisation car il sait que toutes
les sociétés modernes deviennent
extrêmement complexe est au bureau 4 il
faut pouvoir décider là où on est des
problèmes qui nous concernent
c'est en route et ça se fera -la
troisième fondation qu'il fallait
changer cette et les relations sociales
les droits des travailleurs
et bien tout ça effet dès aujourd'hui
c'est les fondations d'une maison
autrement dit il suffit pas de jouer les
pompiers pour éteindre le feu de
l'inflation il fallait reconstruire les
fondations de la maison et ce sont ces
trois réformes que nous sommes attachés
d'affaires au prix d'un très grand
effort demandé aussi au parlement et à
la nation pour comprendre et suivre tout
cela polk pas une dernière question et
une dernière réponse rapide au quart
d'heure est épuisée si on permettait de
rester sur l'expression de timidité ce
qui n'a pas aussi une certaine timidité
dans un domaine que vous connaissez bien
qui est celui du plan autrefois c'était
une ardente obligation du temps du
général de gaulle est aujourd'hui pour
qu'on est l'expression des trains p
polémique
on a l'impression que c'est un peu un os
à ronger que l'on a donné un ministre
surdoué et pour qu'ils s'occupent avec
cette affaire et ce n'est plus nord dans
une ardente obligation de l'ensemble du
gouvernement et de la nation et vous
aurez de bonnes surprises avec la
préparation du prochain plan car plus
l'avenir est incertain plus les temps
sont durs
plus on a besoin de baliser la route et
d'éclairer l'avenir
par conséquent le prochain plan
permettra à tous les français et aux
entreprises de mieux voir quels sont les
enjeux de l'avenir puisque dans le fond
l'heure de vérité s'est aussi appréciée
des enjeux quels sont les enjeux de
l'avenir quelles sont les grandes
orientations de l'économie française
quels sont les grands combats qu'ils
font mais qu'il faut mener quels sont
les grands pari industriel il convient
de prendre
il redeviendra une ardente obligation
sinon il sera adaptée à son époque
l'ardente obligation c'est de survivre
et de gagner la guerre économique
le plan est un moyen pour monsieur le
ministre nous avons changé
d'interlocuteur alors nouveau tirage au
sort vous choisissez le numéro un ou
numéro 3 numéros un numéro 1 serge july
de libération laure serge ligue et on
enchaîne tout de suite le deuxième quart
d'heure par m je commençais de leur s
que puisque de l'émission s'appelle
l'heure de vérité est que je crois que
ce qui définit la gauche par rapport à
la droite général c'est qu'elle n'a pas
peur de la vérité avant tout cas qu'elle
n'a pas peur de dire la vérité à
l'opinion publique
alors peut-on dire oui ou non
aujourd'hui nous nous trouvons dans une
situation qui impose une véritable
politique d'austérité c'est à dire qu'il
va demander des sacrifices à tout le
monde à toutes les catégories sociales
tous les partenaires sociaux oui on peut
dire ça oui sans ambiguïté il faudra que
chacun renonce un peu à ce qu'il croit
devoir obtenir à ses droits il faudra un
effort de tous mais cet effort nous
avons voulu le fonds l'a fondée sur la
solidarité d'où ma conversation avec
copains est ce que ça veut dire que par
exemple en ce qui concerne les
allocations de chômage il y aura une
réduction de l'allocation de chômage
seul à faire des partenaires sociaux
tout système peut être amélioré
il ne s'agit pas de renoncer à
l'indemnisation du chômage
il s'agit peut-être de mieux adapter des
indemnités de façon à mieux inciter les
gens à chercher du travail
il y a deux millions de chômeurs je me
garderai de verser des larmes de
crocodile ou de houe de préconiser des
solutions miracles mais ce que je peux
dire d'expérience aujourd'hui c'est que
sur ces deux millions de chômeurs
il y en a certains qui pourrait trouver
un travail si notre politique active de
l'emploi était meilleure si les services
qu'on mettait à la disposition des
chômeurs étaient mieux agencé de plus
grande qualité est aussi si lorsqu'on
leur propose un travail il ya une
différence sensible de rémunération avec
ce qu'ils touchent comme chômeurs alors
y'a quand même un principe simple celui
qui travaille doit être mieux en mieux
rémunérés que celui qui est qui se forme
qui fait un effort pour se former et
celui qui fait un effort pour se former
doit être mieux rémunérés que celui qui
a qui attend chez lui qu'un travail
arrive alors quel type de sacrifice de
les demander dans quelle direction vous
allez demander aux partenaires sociaux
de chercher eh bien nous allons leur
demander de chercher dans plusieurs
directions
d'abord le mot sacrifice est un peu fort
il y a la sagesse et sacrifice la
sagesse c'est de croire que l'on peut
vivre aussi bien et même mieux avec 8 %
de hausse des prix qu'avec 14
dans les deux cas on ne demande pas de
sacrifice puisque notre politique est
fondée sur le maintien du pouvoir
d'achat
des salariés de tous les français et non
sur le recul comme dans d'autres pays
mais c'est plus facile à faire et
l'économie française en tir à plus de
profits si nous le faisons à 8% ce qui
est mon objectif pour 1983 que si on le
fait à 14%
dois-je ajouter qu'un point d'inflation
en moins ses cinquante mille
travailleurs embauchés en plus quant aux
sacrifices
il s'agit que les français se rendent
compte que les dépenses de sécurité
sociale ne pourront plus croître au même
rythme sans que il disait à perdre du
salaire direct et un choix fondamental
actuellement seul henry sur le ticket
modérateur sur les dépenses
hospitalières ça ce sera une
concertation entre des organisations
syndicales le patronat et le
gouvernement
mais je crois qu'il ya un chiffre que
l'on peut donner aux français
qu'est ce qu'on peut espérer dans les
années à venir comme le taux de
croissance de l'économie entre 3 et 4%
pourtant pour cette année la prévision
c'est 2,5 moi je veux dire tu mets ton
même prenons un chiffre de 3 à 4 c pour
ma démonstration c'est le maximum que
l'on peut obtenir de combien augmente
les dépenses sociales
elle augmente de 6% par an ça fait donc
un creux d'environ 25 milliards ça veut
dire deux points de cotisations sociales
par an ça veut donc dire deux points de
hausse de salaire en moins alors il faut
que les français choisissent ou bien ils
veulent du salaire direct ou bien ils
veulent des transferts sociaux
à londres on dit faisons payer sa part
le budget de l'état bon mais ça veut
dire à ce moment là qu'il faut augmenter
de 10 ou 20%
le rendement de l'impôt sur le revenu de
toute façon les français auront à payer
soit en touchant moins de salaires
directs soit en payant peu d'un plus
d'impôts dirais mais cette distance
entre le revenu qui est possible
d'accéder et puis les transferts sociaux
il faut le combler il faut le combler de
deux manières en cotisant d'une part
l'impôt par l'est ou par le prélèvement
sur les salaires et sur les entreprises
ou bien en s'attachant à diminuer le
rythme de croissance de dépenses et ma
conviction personnelle c'est qu'on peut
soigner mieux en soigner en moins cher
est-ce que
l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
sont partagent cette opinion je vous
pose cette question
pas du tout dans un souci de polémique
mais tout simplement parce qu'à deux
reprises en 24 heures vous avez sinon
mis en question du moins émis des doutes
sur la question des 39 heures vous
l'avait fait une première fois en
recevant la fédération cédétiste des
banques et vous l'avez fait si j'ai bien
compris vos déclarations au monde dans
les conditions vous avez dit tout à
l'heure vous avez remis en question la
question des 39 vous avez dit qu'en fait
ce n'était pas créateur d'emploi vous
avait contesté l'expression erreur enfin
me dicte une interprétation hâtive
est ce que en tout cas en tout cas je
n'ai pas dit ça à mes camarades de la
cfdt de la banque
je leur ai dit ce que je vais vous
répéter le passage de 40 heures à 39
heures
on l'a fait pour tout le monde pour
montrer que vraiment on ne laisser
personne de côté
et ce passage de 40 heures à 39 heures
il a été intégralement compenser et
c'est ce qui explique la hausse du
salaire horaire au premier trimestre de
cette année 4,8 pour cent car il n'y a
que 3 % en réalité de salaire et 1,8
pour cent de compensation mais cette
passage de 40 euros 39 heures ou pas
militaire n'a pas permis de créer
d'emplois j'ai donc dit simplement je
continue à penser qu'il faut faire le
partage du travail pour lutter contre le
chômage c'est à dire travailler moins
individuellement pour travailler plus
collectivement casser cette non
solidarité entre ceux qui ont un emploi
et ceux qui n'en n'ont pas mais on ne
peut pas le faire par la méthode de
passage de 39 à 38 de 38 à 37 c ça veut
dire que très rapidement vous souhaitez
qui est une nouvelle diminution de la
durée du travail donc sans l'équivalent
il est pas au pad militaire avec un coup
de sifflet du gouvernement par des
négociations dans les entreprises là où
c'est possible et alors il ya par
exemple une entreprise qui viennent
passer à 35 heures par un ensemble qui
créent des emplois et bien chaque
entreprise doit négocier il faut se
rapprocher des faits jeu ce que j'ai
voulu dire c'est que le passage au pas
cadencé de 39 à 30,8 et à 37 ne créerait
pas d'emplois
or l'heure n'est pas venue de diminuer
le travail avec la guerre économique
les compétiteurs que l'on a face à nous
il faut travailler davantage
je trouve qu'il y en a qui n'en n'ont
pas du tout de travail alors partageant
le avec eux et au total travaillons plus
est ce que vous pensez que le pari
économique est elle votre le scénario
économique qui était le vôtre et celui
de françois mitterrand en juin dernier
qui consistait à dire on répare un peu
les erreurs qui avaient fait bar c'est à
dire on fait une véritable décompression
on relance donc la dépense sociale et
donc par autant relance la consommation
et ce faisant va atteindre la relance
économique internationale est-ce que
vous pensez que ce scénario est toujours
valable je vous pose la question parce
que les résultats sur la production
industrielle indice actuel est
équivalent à l' indice de l'année
dernière la mairie
c'est à dire c'est à dire donc on a le
sentiment quand même que la relance que
vous avez provoqué n'a duré qu'un seul
et et serge july
les choses sont simples dessus je répète
mon image de tout à l'heure l'année
dernière nous étions à 50 kilomètres à
l'heure en voiture là nous sommes à 70
km lundi la production industrielle
n'est pas un bon indice nous savons que
nous sommes au dessus
la preuve c'est que la consommation des
français augmente de l'ennemi % à 3 % en
volume par an mais ceux qui troublent
les observateurs à juste titre c'est
qu'au lieu de passer de 70 à 80 puis à
90 m ça leur en ce moment nous sommes
comme ça nous restons à 110 pourquoi
parce que les autres voitures du convoi
c'est à dire les autres pays qui roule à
40 à l'heure et que nous ne pouvons pas
prendre trop d'avancé sur eux car chaque
fois que nous prenons de la banque sur
eux
nous achetons davantage à l'étranger et
nous leur vendons moins et vous dépensez
pas justement qu'on a trop d'avant nous
verte est incertain certains disent
la france va avoir trop d' avance d'une
certaine manière nous que le
différentiel d'inflation va être de 6%
hors jeu ou alors nous reviendrons là
dessus mais ou bien nous faisions la
purge est à ce moment là nous serions
dans la situation des autres mais avec
deux millions et demi de chômeurs nous
n'avons pas été élus pour ça et ça c'est
démoraliser la nation je le répète non
nous essayons simplement d'aller à un
rythme pas trop rapide mais il ya eu 2 2
fait très important qui ont bien entendu
peser sur la situation dans le monde
entier
c'est du la persistance des taux
d'intérêt élevés aux états unis et en
février une sorte de climat
psychologique qui est venu de l'ouest
des
ats-unis toutes les grandes entreprises
ont coupé leurs investissements ce a eu
un effet négatif sur l'ensemble du monde
occidental y compris même au japon
ce qui fait qu'en ce moment nous ne
sommes plus en récession
du point de vue physique nous sommes six
co logiquement est presque physiquement
en dépression et c'est ce qui justifie
mes inquiétudes et c'est ce qui justifie
aussi que le président de la république
attache autant d'importance au sommet de
versailles
même s'ils n'en attend pas des miracles
l'immédiat à ce propos certains
et experts socialistes au sein du parti
socialiste évoque la possibilité de
décrocher les taux d'intérêt en france
des taux d'intérêts internationaux nous
avons déjà décroché puisque à dire de
faire un double marché mais nous nous le
faisons en pratique nous avons un taux
sur le marché monétaire qui est de
l'ordre de 16 3 8e pour défendre notre
monnaie et le taux de base bancaire et
de 14% nous avons même fait mieux
j'ai dégagé 24 milliards de crédits
bonifiés pour les investissements des
entreprises et 3 milliards et demi de
francs de prêts participatifs et mardi
prochain 7 de mes collaborateurs vont
dans cette région voir si ça marche et
si les méthodes de financement qui ont
été mis au point à des taux pour du long
terme de trait et demi pour cent ce qui
est avantageux à des taux de 6 à 8 %
pour les prêts participatifs
si je vois que les techniques mises en
oeuvre ne marche pas bien
nous ferons une réunion de synthèse et
nous changerons tout cela donc nous
pratiquons déjà savez en france les deux
tiers des crédits accordés sont des
crédits bonifiés crédit à l'exportation
crédits au logement et autres alors la
dualité des taux elle existe ce qu'on a
ce qu'on appelle et je crois depuis
plusieurs années la ligne de l'or n'est
pas par hasard vous avez été l'inventeur
la politique contractuelle
c'est ce qu'on appelle l' échange des
concessions c'est à dire que un
partenaire social une couche sociale est
une corporation fait une concession et
pour autant une autre cette fête en
relation avec elle ou celle qui dans une
relation patronale avec elle fait une
autre concession
or de fait depuis un an n'a pas le
sentiment que ça fonctionne exactement
comme ça je veux dire par là que on a
plutôt le sentiment qu'il ya des
pressions qui s'exercent sur le
gouvernement
je pense par exemple ses 39 heures a été
interprétée quand même comme une
concession qui était fait à un moment
donné à la cgt parce qu'il y avait eu un
mouvement de grève une certaine
agitation organisée par la cgt pour
d'autres cas c'était le cas des routiers
sur la détaxation du gazole on n'a pas
le plus récemment le cas de ce qu'on a
appelé peut-être un peu rapidement les
cadeaux au patronat
alors qu'on n'a pas bien vu quelles
concessions ont été faites
de l'autre côté et on a vu certaines
mères des concessions qui étaient faites
étaient accordées à des couches sociales
et on n'a pas vu sans qu'elle soit
concessions
qui va la chose qui était rendu par là
où on a le sentiment et si je puis me
permettre
on a le sentiment que la ligne de leur
est parfois entravés au gouvernement non
des zazous des ajustements sont
nécessaires
après un an de pratique gouvernementale
en fonction des faits il est vrai qu'il
ya toujours en france le risque de
résurgence des corporatismes chaque
groupe se pousse en avant si vous cédez
vous partez dans une ligne infernal vous
êtes toujours d'accord avec l'analyse
que faisait réforme en au début des
années 60 sur le fait que c'était une
caractéristique française que ces sacs
expliqué qu'ils avaient toujours quatre
ou cinq pansements l'inflation plus dans
un certain sens oui mais vous voyez
maintenant que cette année est passée
que le changement s'est fait paisible le
mans quand même bien que le haut niveau
politique dans le dialogue jaras des
chaufferies un peu de radicalisation les
français aiment ça mais il en faut pas
trop parce que dans le fond on est là
tous comme dans une cordée pour
travailler ensemble
eh bien je rêve maintenant d'une grande
politique syndicale pour le gouvernement
l'un des grands atouts d'un gouvernement
de la gauche
ça doit être une coopération avec les
syndicats dans l'autre fois j'ai jeté un
petit pavé dans la mare le regrettez pas
regretter vos déclarations
j'étais 20 ans syndicaliste on se parle
comme ça dans le syndicalisme alors je
vois pas pourquoi aujourd'hui je ne
pourrais pas parler comme cela mais
c'est à dire vous leur dites qu'ils ne
se transforment pas assez vite je leur
dis simplement réfléchi c'est est ce que
le goût on peut que vous pouvez garder
avec le nouveau gouvernement le même
comportement qu'avec l'ancien alors
aussitôt on dire oh la la il veut faire
du syndicalisme courroie de transmission
du patronat on peut pas dire ça de moi
qui en 2009 69 72 me suis battu contre
la majorité d'alors est temps pris pour
un gauchiste pour donner aux syndicats
leur place dans la société
alors qu'on réserve ce genre d'écrits de
mikado si la question sur les syndicats
s'opposent monsieur de l'or aujourd'hui
simplement qu'on n'a pas le sentiment un
an après ses voeux l'arrivée de la
gauche au pouvoir que les syndicats ont
eu un formidable développement en france
en respectivement depuis des années vous
des typhons un syndicalisme fort en
volant il n'est pas possible de faire
une politique d'austérité ou un effort
collectif si les syndicalistes enfants
j'en perds tu n'as pas ce sentiment
qui se renforce je persiste et signe je
suis toujours partisan de l'est mais
qu'est ce qui est fait pour qu'il se
renforce on a bien dit mais on a le
sentiment inverse au contraire on a
l'impression que la courbe est plutôt
bien non il faut dire ça sera un autre
sujet et les dirigeants syndicaux sont
mieux placés que moi pour vous en parler
il faut dire qu'il ya actuellement une
crise du syndicalisme sans que le mot
est un sens péjoratif je veux dire que
lorsqu'il faut à la fois se partager les
responsabilités de la politique
économique pour lutter contre le chômage
puis défendre les intérêts moraux et
matériels des travailleurs donner à tous
le sentiment de la solidarité ça n'est
pas facile je serai plus j'aurais plutôt
tendance à rendre hommage aux dirigeants
syndicaux qui essaient de faire passer
ça à leurs militants et leurs militants
au maire à l'orteil de corporal à
disposition ses pas vers l'avant
dernière ne s'adressait pas à eux
comment la critique de corporatisme
c'est vrai c'est pas la direction des
noms non parce que je trouve que les
dirigeants syndicaux et notamment ceux
qui vont suivre un congrès la semaine
prochaine font un gros êtres aux efforts
pour faire passer l'idée de solidarité
active dans la nation dernière question
monsieur delarue faisait le sentiment
quand on est ministre de l'économie
qu'on demande beaucoup d'efforts et dans
un gouvernement de gauche le parti
socialiste joue un rôle quand même très
important et c'est un handicap pour vous
de ne pas être un élu écoutez je d'abord
j'étais parlementaire européen mais je
fais de bien me poser la question parce
que je voulais vous présenter muni cipal
s'attendait attendait le jour de
l'émouvante cérémonie du panthéon où
était alors qu'il ait pas de
gouvernement qu'un premier ministre
j'étais déjà envahi france
ensuite quand le président de la
république m'a demandé d'être ministre
de l'économie et des finances je lui ai
dit bah écoutez je vais quand même aller
faire une petite campagne électorale du
côté de brive par la n10 vous croyez que
c'est compatible avec votre travail en
groupe
priorité à votre travail et maintenant
il va vous laisser du temps et donc on a
marre nez comme des chiens pendant tout
l'été on a préparé tous les textes sur
l'année 6 nationalisation j'ai vu
moi-même le dossier de 50 entreprises
pour voir quel était le genre de
difficultés leurs rapports avec les
banquiers et cetera on n'a pas pris un
jour de vacances ni mes collaborateurs
ni moi même mais voilà maintenant
maintenant vous allez prendre ce temps
là par exemple dans le cas des
prochaines municipales est ce que ça
vous manque pas d'être élu
qu'en termes d'autorité par rapport au
parti socialiste est ce que ça ne vous
manque pas bruit des fois il arrive
qu'on me dise dans une réunion si tu
étais élu local tu saurais que alors
ceci me pousserait plutôt à le faire
mais est-ce compatible avec le travail
d'un ministre de l'économie et des
finances qui est à la fois un bâtisseur
et un pompier qui doit et qui peut être
appelé à l'heure du jour ou de la nuit
pour soi boucher un trou éteindre un feu
ou faire une petite construction une
petite pile de plus la question est
posée mais pour l'instant je trouverai
pas le moyen merci pour nos terrasses
dépense donc passage au deuxième inter
locuteurs avoir dans mon esprit il n'y a
pas de surprise pour vous je l'annoncé
philippe vasseur de rédacteur en chef du
nouveau journal je serais presque tenté
de dire du nouveau nouveau journal
puisque c'est un confrère qui vient de
changer de formule
conserver ces deux-là compliments je
vous remercie combien de temps même si
le journal ne nous gâte guerre
j'essaierai de ne pas vous guettez non
plus ce soit un bon combien de temps
pensez-vous pouvoir éviter une
dévaluation du franc pendant plusieurs
mois pendant plusieurs semaines
oui pendant plusieurs mois parce que la
compétitivité de notre économie est
encore bonne
nous la mesure ont tous les mois
soigneusement elle dépend de quoi notre
compétitivité
premièrement de la productivité en
second lieu des coûts de production en
troisième lieu de la volonté de vendre à
l'étranger et de se battre
et bien si je considère ces trois
éléments notre compétitivité vis-à-vis
de toutes les monnaies demeure positive
qu'est ce qui se passe donc eh bien il
me semble et je voudrais se dire cela
sans agressivité comme j'ai parlé des
syndicats il me semble que les chefs
d'entreprise sont un peu découragé
évidemment c'est une moyenne une
constatation globale comme ça n'a pas de
sens quand je dis ça monsieur gattaz il
me dit venez voir mon entreprise venez
voir telle entreprise
mais je comprends un petit peu ce
découragement
d'abord c'est un gouvernement qui leur
plaît - je dirais pas que le précédent
parce que le professeur barry leur tirer
les oreilles pour qu'ils investissent et
ils investissaient pas vous les avez pas
gâté non plus chantants bien mais
essayons quand même de de trouver une
bonne voie de compromis avec eux et en
tout cas pour ma part je les consulte je
vais les voir j'essaie de comprendre
leurs problèmes et je voudrais vous dire
quelque chose qui m'apparaît plus
fondamental même si c'est sous forme
d'une question
ils sont un peu découragé et pas depuis
que la gauche est au pouvoir même un peu
avant
car c'est dur d'être chef d'entreprise
aujourd'hui c'est dur de se battre sans
arrêt je pense à ce qui ce depuis 20 ou
30 ans dirige leur entreprise exerce des
responsabilités doivent faire face au
financement du progrès social à une
compétition de plus en plus agressive
venant de pays dont les coûts de
production sont plus faibles que nous
face à un univers bancaire et
bureaucratique est parfois difficile à
percer donc moi mon ambition même si on
me qualifie pour sa de modérer c'est
quand même temps
cliff j'aurai un bon dialogue avec les
syndicats une coopération conflictuelle
je me fasse mieux comprendre des chefs
d'entreprise et eux on retrouve des
perspectives positives pour l'avenir
c'est à dire que l'économie redeviennent
visible pour eux ne croyez pas qu'il
faudrait d'abord que vous fassiez mieux
comprendre d'un certain nombre de vos
collègues du gouvernement
parce qu'ici les patrons sont découragés
c'est parce que vous avez peut-être un
peu chargé la barque aussi nous avons
s'il est vrai que l'effort de solidarité
a coûté à tout le monde juge n'a pas
seulement de coûts financiers et aussi
le coût social il ya un certain nombre
de réglementations nouvelles leur écoute
et prenons cela un peu un les lois
auroux où les lois sur les droits des
travailleurs
qu'est ce que j'entends pas eh bien si
je vous les expliquer endroit phrases et
si les chefs d'entreprise qui m'écoutent
les équipes veulent b à m'écouter
qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce que c'est
que les lois auroux ça vise à mettre les
relations sociales en france au niveau
où elles sont en allemagne en belgique
en suède
et ça se résume à trois mots
premièrement les travailleurs et leurs
syndicats doivent pouvoir négocier au
niveau de l'entreprise des salaires
réels des conditions de travail de
l'organisation du travail
deuxièmement il est normal que chaque
travailleur hills et leurs représentants
soient mieux informés de la marche de
l'entreprise de façon que l'on fasse une
équipe c'est à dire le modèle japonais
transforme transposé à la française
bon il est donc important qu'il y ait un
comité de groupe auprès d'une holding
il est important que dans les petites
entreprises on puisse se regrouper pour
que les travailleurs puissent comprendre
ce qui se passe et troisièmement pouvoir
s'exprimer sur leurs conditions de
travail leur demander leur avis vous
remarquerez que tous les pays qui ont
fait des progrès décisifs en matière
d'innovation et de productivité ces
dernières années ont pratiqué une
politique d'expression des travailleurs
d'une manière ou d'une autre il y à la
façon japonaise jaea façon suédoise est
la façon allemande
il faut inventer une façon française
nous on ne peut pas dire à des gens
travaillent et tais toi aujourd'hui
c'est trop compliqué il faut intéresser
les gens au travail
on ne peut pas attaquer le travail sur
deux plans en le rendant inintéressant
d'un côté en multipliant de chômage de
l'autre
par conséquent les lois qui sont
actuellement discutées par le parlement
et dont le coup quand elles seront
appliquées dans leur sambre près
représentera 0,30 pour cent de la masse
des salaires ces lois sont
indispensables pour changer l'état
d'esprit dans l'entreprise en france et
faire que chacun puisse aller le matin
ce travail en se disant je vais pas
travailler simplement pour gagner un
salaire mais j'y serai utile
il est obligatoire pour cela de d'avoir
comme interlocuteur obligatoire les
syndicats même dans les entreprises où
ils sont très peu représentés mais c'est
le grand problème que posait serge july
tout à l'heure des syndicats forts c'est
pas amusant mais c'est mieux pour une
nation c'est mieux dans l'intérêt
général que des syndicats faible des
syndicats forts qui peuvent expliquer
aux travailleurs
ce qu'il est nécessaire de faire pour
que la nation puisse progresser les
sacrifices à partager entre tous les
entre tout le monde sait mieux que des
syndicats faible je vous dis les que la
modernisation de l'économie française
depuis 20 ans a été entravée en partie
bien que nous ayons obtenu des succès
par le fait que l'on a voulu reléguer
les syndicats et qu'on s'est contenté du
rôle qu'ils avaient au lieu de leur
tendre la main
et rappelez vous des articles que j'ai
fait après les élections de 78 la
dernière victoire législative de la
droite
monsieur giscard d'estaing a dit
l'ouverture sociale il a reçu les
syndicats le patronat l'a dit ils ne
l'ont pas fait ce jour là ils ont perdu
des élections ils ont perdu une grande
chance pour la france
j'ai pas rester sur les projets de lois
auroux parce que vous n'êtes pas
ministre du travail mme ministre de
l'économie je vous ai entendu à
plusieurs rues ici sociale ne va pas
avec l'économique d'accord mais on va
dans une heure de vérité on n'a pas le
temps d'aborder tous les problèmes
je vous ai entendu parler à deux ou
trois reprises tout à l'heure de guerre
économique
c'est un mot qu'on n'avait pas tellement
entendu dans la bouche des socialistes
il ya un an
les socialistes nous avait plutôt laissé
entendre qu'une fois au pouvoir il
arriverait avec des recettes qui
permettrait d'améliorer la situation on
peut discuter du bilan mais enfin la
situation est quand même resté assez
grave
alors de deux choses l'une où les
socialistes je ne parle pas de vous
avait conscience de la gravité de la
situation internationale mais ils ont
que ça à décourager les électeurs et on
n'a pas trop parlé
chacun appréciera ou alors ils
n'allaient pas conscience et c'est un
peu de légèreté et quelle est la bonne
réponse est bien bonne réponse elle
réside dans un fait historique en 1974
lors de la précédente campagne
présidentielle françois mitterrand a dit
il s'agit d'une crise profonde
non pas d'une crise de courte durée et
valéry giscard d'estaing à ce moment là
a dit mme c'est une crise de courte
durée la politique qui a été suivi par
monsieur chirac monsieur fourcade
dans le cas des orientations de monsieur
giscard d'estaing était une politique
qui se fondait sur la base d'une crise
de courte durée et c'est le même valéry
giscard d'estaing qui a parlé de
croissance douce alors entre la
croissance douce et le défi économique
il ya quand même une différence et ce
sont les socialistes qui ont dit dès le
début attention ne vous fige et pas sur
la hausse du prix du pétrole
le monde occidental traverse une crise
profonde de longue durée qui demandera
des mutations assez importante et nous
nous voulons armée la société française
et son économie pour qu'elle puisse
faire face à ces défis
enfin quand vous êtes arrivé au pouvoir
vous avez essayé de relancer l'activité
en privilégiant la consommation
on peut pas dire que ça a été un grand
succès vous disais tout à l'heure quand
cinquante six mois monsieur barbe effet
huit cent mille chômeurs en douze mois à
peu près de gouvernement le gouvernement
de monsieur moreau en effet trois cent
mille de plus ces gardiens mais n'ont
échoué qu'à ce jeu je ne dis pas les
voix qui se sont portées la
responsabilité de chiffres sont faux je
vais vous donner ce nom peuvent en effet
il ya 300 milles de chômage urbain
regardez regardez le rythme de
décélération d'abord vous êtes un trop
bon économiste pour pas savoir qu'il ya
de l'inertie en économie est ce la
panique c'était de notre faute bon je
dis simplement que la motion magic n'a
pas opéré
non mais ya pas de potion magique je ne
nous n'avons jamais dit qu'il y avait de
potion magique
nous avons dit simplement que la france
devait se réconcilier avec elle même que
ceux qui étaient trop longtemps écarté
du pouvoir devait pouvoir participer à
l'effort dans l'ensemble c'est ça que
nous avons des quantas quant au chômage
permettait le rythme de croissance était
de 17% il est passé à dix et pour les
derniers mois il est à 5% alors qu'il
est plus de 50 % en allemagne
oui c'est vraiment ça se stabilise en
allemagne oui mais plus 50% vous
avouerez que c'est quand même à ses
électeurs que lincou lubac nous bien sûr
mais enfin il faut pas oublier qu'entre
temps la récession économique
internationale s'est aggravée vous ne
contestez pas ça au moins non pas du
tout mais je pense que la récession
économique internationale existe depuis
longtemps oui mais s'est aggravée et pas
suffisamment par s'est aggravée s'est
aggravée c'est personne ne le conteste
regardez même nos adversaires politiques
ou les journaux qui ne sont pas
favorables ils s'inquiètent sur le fait
que la hausse des taux d'intérêt se
maintient aux états unis que l'on
atteint actuellement en termes réels des
taux d'intérêt qui décourage
l'investissement que le dollar fait des
mouvements imprévisibles que partout il
ya recul de la production industrielle
sauf en france
par conséquent il faut bien voir que si
la droite avait été élue elle aurait eu
une sacrée situation devant elle
nous ne sommes plus en mise en eau début
de 1980 plus une crise dure plus elle
s'aggrave
c'est bien ça la préoccupation centrale
est ce qu'aujourd'hui les pays
occidentaux qui vont se réunir à
versailles qui sont des alliés
politiques entre eux qui aura juste
titre se préoccupe de l' équilibre des
forces entre l'est et l'ouest
est ce que ces pays occidentaux vous
comprendre que la bataille qui veulent
mener semaine autant sur le plan
économique et social que sur le plan
diplomatique et militaire
car si les américains continuent leur
politique actuelle d' insensibilité à
tous les autres ce qu'ils gagneront sur
le plan diplomatique ou militaire
ils le perdront et l'occident tout
entier sur le plan économique et social
voilà le message que nous disons depuis
un an ce n'est pas un message de
facilité
mais monsieur dehors les experts de la
cdo de cdo c'est l'organisation des pays
industriels ne sont pas tout à fait
d'accord avec vous et avec l'analyse
pour les mois qui viennent ils disent
dans leurs prévisions officieuses qu'en
principe en 1983 il devrait y avoir une
reprise de la croissance à peu près dans
tous les pays sauf en france on assiste
au contraire à un tassement compte tenu
du fait que nous avons une inflation
très nettement supérieure à tous les
autres pays industrialisés
en prenant le risque de la relance en
juillet dernier nous savions que nous
aurions agir est soigneusement de
clignotants celui des prix et celui du
commerce extérieur plus la récession
s'accroît plus le risque est grand sur
le commerce extérieur et nous aurons
encore des difficultés je peux le dire
dès maintenant j'en suis sûr et en ce
qui concerne les prix plus vite nous
aboutirons à 8%
mieux ce sera pour nous voilà ce qui est
en cause
nous sommes obligés de tenir compte de
ce qui se passe à l'extérieur mais nous
n'allons pas changer de politique
parce que les autres en fonte en font
une différente nous n'allons pas infligé
à la france une purge qui laissera notre
économie comme un corps malade sur un
lit incapable de se relever
alors que depuis dix ans il ya un manque
dramatique d'investissement alors qu'il
ya des gens quittent qui traverse les
rues à ne rien faire qui sont au chômage
nous sommes obligés de concilier la
lutte contre le chômage et la lutte
contre l'inflation
nous ne cédons pas à la politique qui
donne la priorité exclusive à la lutte
contre l'inflation et nous ne cédons pas
non plus à danser politique à celle qui
privilégie la politique monétaire sans
être capable de résoudre leurs problèmes
budgétaires confèrent les états unis et
monsieur de l'or les cartes c'est quand
même aggravée entre la hausse des prix
dans les principaux pays étrangers la
hausse des prix en france c'est la
contrepartie de la croatie qui arrêtait
0,7 pour cent en 1984 pour 180 on est
aujourd'hui à 6% écouter villa
vous voulez parler voulait pas rentrer
les la moyenne des principaux pays
industrialisés les pays de l' ocde comme
on dit c'est donc principaux partenaires
nos principaux concurrents et nous oui
mais d'un vrai dire qu'un produit
français qui vaut mais ton sang froid au
début de l'année et bien par rapport au
fait nous avons fait un réalignement
monétaire qui nous a permis de retrouver
les bases d'une compétitivité scène
au train où vont les choses vous serez
obligés d'en faire un deuxième mais mes
douze nous verrons à la fin de l'année
en fonction du mouvement des monnaies
des hausses réelles des prix des
perspectives de croissance
mais on ne peut pas d'un côté avoir de
la croissance comme nous en avons
ralentir très nettement la croissance du
chômage et en même temps décéléré sur
les prix à toute vitesse ou alors il
fallait bloquer les prix mais c'est une
illusion ou pratiquer la purge ce dont
nous nous refusons pour les raisons que
j'ai déjà indiqué alors dernière
question du bonheur toute dernière
question que c'est de l'art je crois que
vous n'avez pas tout à fait répondu à la
question de cergy tout à l'heure quand
ils vous disent est ce que la ligne de
l'or n'est pas quelquefois entravé au
sein du gouvernement
alors vous venez ce soir d'exprimer un
certain nombre de grands principes de
rigueur d'efforts vous savez qu'il ya
des moments dans la vie où les
circonstances ou bien des autorités
dites supérieures vous oblige à
contrebalancer alors que vos principes
voyez ce que je veux dire
et si cela devait arriver dans les
prochains mois qu'est ce que vous feriez
côté je suis membre d'une équipe dans
cette équipe
grâce au style donné par françois
mitterrand et pierre mauroy au travail
gouvernemental je peux m'exprimer je ne
vois pas pourquoi on me donnait toujours
raison à moi les autres ont aussi des
arguments
je fais partie de cette équipe et même
si un jour je sors un peu meurtri d'un
arbitrage qui ne me plaît pas quand je
regrette la conduite de la droite
française
son incivisme sa manière démagogique de
parler de la france et du franc français
eh bien ça m'en donne envie de rester
quoique en coûte car le bataille de la
gauche contre la droite
cessons 2 qui la déclenche en ce moment
demain dans un hebdomadaire
on monte les trois cavaliers de
l'opposition valéry giscard d'estaing
jacques chirac et raymond barre et a
marqué les trois cavaliers de
l'opposition quand je les écoute
j'aurais envie de titre et ce journal
les trois cavaliers de la pop
lips ses ministres sont arrivés nous
entrons dans le quatrième quart d'heure
de cette émission et nous allons vous
tourner maintenant vers spp pour savoir
premièrement si les spectateurs
satisfaits de vos réponses
deuxièmement quel type de questions il
souhaite vous poser alors j'appelle là
bas laurenceau harvin et christian mary
mono est ce que vous entendez absolument
françois riz et je peux vous assurer que
nous sommes très surpris par la quantité
de questions posées c'est un simple
échantillon je vous assure des questions
ce qui prouve bien les préoccupations
des français concernant la vie
économique et les décisions du
gouvernement à la matière alors nous
avons sélectionné quelques questions
tout d'abord le problème les inégalités
laurent oui la série de questions ou de
témoignages après un an de changement il
ya toujours trop de gens riches et trop
de gens pauvres il ya encore trop
d'inégalités dit monsieur de l'ofj a
fonctionné à melun
comment peut-on vivre à deux avec un
salaire de 2900 francs demande monsieur
dupont aversa i les manoeuvres bensimon
et secrétaires bagnols et elle vit dans
un hlm est elle pour quatre pièces elles
payer un loyer de 500 francs 12 100
points de charge quelle solution
demande-t-elle quand monsieur de l'or
va-t-il se décider à faire payer les
riches demande monsieur gleizes
enseignants à la celle saint cloud
comptez vous mener à bout l'impôt sur la
fortune demande madame nicolas
traductrice à courbevoie et une question
plus générale posée par monsieur lien
aux étudiants à reims
comment peut-on faire de l'économie et
du social en même temps ou bien le
progrès social peut-il contribuer à la
relance économique
monsieur de l'or va certainement pas
répond à toutes ces questions dont je
vous proposais de lui faire parvenir
effectivement ces questions et il
prendra son temps pour y répondre mais
vous allez imposer une précise
actuellement à laquelle il va répondre
la question la plus précise et la plus
générale disons qui nous est posée qui
résume toutes les autres c'est comment
peut-on faire de l'économie du social en
même temps est-ce que le progrès social
peut contribuer à la relance économique
s'il vous plaît vous m'en voyez toutes
ces questions avec leurs auteur es
nous tâche cette analyse les réponses ne
serai pas déçu ses milices car nous
avons effectivement les centaines de
questions ici sur cette question je
répondrai simplement puisqu'il s'agit de
faire un effort collectif
cet effort ne peut être fait que dans la
solidarité c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui
plus que puisque dans d'autres temps le
progrès social conditionne le progrès
économique
alors pendant les années de forte
croissance on pouvait très bien dire le
contraire le progrès social dépendent et
du progrès économique
aujourd'hui pour redonner à la nation la
cohésion le sens qu'on fait partie d'une
même équipe il faut que le progrès
social enclenche le progrès économique
et il peut le faire de deux manières par
une solidarité plus active entre les
français et les questions posées
montrent qu'il ya encore beaucoup à
faire et aussi paru par un changement du
climat dans l'entreprise qu'ils fassent
de chaque travailleur un acteur actif du
changement voilà en quoi le progrès
social est aujourd'hui un préalable à
tout progrès économique et je dirais
puisque la période est grave à un
sursaut national
autre question alors monsieur le
ministre la préoccupation également de
beaucoup de téléspectateurs exprimé par
monsieur legrand qui est ingénieur à
grenoble pourquoi avoir augmenté cette
tva de 17,6 à 18,6 pour cent cette tva
non les socialistes ont toujours
condamné estimait que c'était un impôt
injuste
et bien parce que le plus le plus
embêtant en ce moment il faut toujours
choisir entre deux inconvénients
le plus ennuyeux aurait été d'aggraver
le déficit budgétaire
alors il y avait donc deux sources
fiscales possibles impôts directs ou
l'impôt indirect
nous avions déjà demandé un peu plus à
l'impôt direct pour contribuer à la
solidarité et au financement de
l'assurance chômage par conséquent il
était normal que nous demandions un peu
à l'impôt indirect à en attendant des
réformes plus profondes mais qui je dois
le dire doivent être très méditer
soigneusement pesé pour les raisons que
j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure en rappelant
les échecs passés
elle débouchera corps la réforme fiscale
débouchera progressivement pas de virage
à 180 degrés tout changement dans la
fiscalité tout changement dans les
systèmes de financement apporte des
perturbations alors les virages doivent
être négociées avec sagesse et douceur
autre question svp autres
sion pourquoi n'avoir fait donner d
accorder des cadeaux aux patrons demande
monsieur bio les ti il escales
techniques banuls pourquoi avoir accordé
des cadeaux aux patrons alors qu'il n'y
a pas de garantie que les
investissements serviront à créer des
emplois
bonne question et parce que monsieur ce
que l'on a fait au titre de la
solidarité représente selon les
entreprises
l'équivalent en salaire de 3 à 5% sur 18
mois et que compte tenu de
l'environnement international
notre économie démarrait très mal par
conséquent la proportion la pesée de ces
coûts supplémentaires sur les revenus
des entreprises et sur leur capacité
d'investissement
cette pesée était trop forte il en
aurait été différemment si les économies
qui sont autour de nous et est reparti
car à ce moment là les entreprises
auraient dégagé plus vite des progrès
productivité puisqu'il n'en a pas été
ainsi nous avons pris l'impôt le plus
répartie la taxe professionnelle un
impôt d'ailleurs qui est très
impopulaire un impôt qui est très anti
économique puisqu'il frappe
l'investissement et l'emploi et le
ministre du budget a trouvé une formule
très original pour permettre d'abaisser
cette taxe et par conséquent de ramener
les coûts des entreprises à des niveaux
supportables
nous avions fait un grand effort pour
ceux dont je parlais tout à l'heure
handicapés familles personnes âgées pour
le smic pour les pour les salariés les
plus modestes
il fallait que les entreprises d'un
autre côté n'est pas une charge trop
fort je le répète si l'économie mondiale
avait repris comme prévu pas seulement
par nous mais par tout le monde
dès janvier dernier il n'aurait pas été
nécessaire de faire cet effort mais
compte tenu de cet environnement
international les charges des
entreprises étaient relativement trop
lourde il fallait les années chez les
spectateurs
oui monsieur le ministre une question
exprimé par monsieur lebreton cabine
lorient qui est une question qui n'est
pas économique mais qui reflète de
nombreuses préoccupations l'a pas ratée
spectateurs je la lis quelques heures en
tant que chrétien cela ne vous gêne-t-il
pas d'être deux à gouvernement qui veut
s'attaquer l'enseignement libre n'a rien
économique mais je pense que ça
intéresse également beaucoup de
téléspectateurs
mais il s'agit pas de s'attaquer à
l'enseignement libre et d'ailleurs s'il
en était ainsi pourquoi monsieur mauroy
et monsieur ça
rires eu du mal à se faire entendre lors
de la journée d'action laïque
il faut dépassionner ce problème ce
n'est vraiment pas la question sur
laquelle doit buts et la société
française dans sa réconciliation avec
elle même il s'agit simplement de
négocier un pluralisme acceptable par
tous et qui permet à chacun de rester
fidèle à ses convictions spirituelles et
philosophiques
en tout cas moi dans ce gouvernement
socialiste si ça peut rassurer monsieur
je ne suis pas du tout inquiet je peux
continuer à aller à la messe le dimanche
par exemple sans que personne ne me le
reproche
par conséquent arrêtons de faire de ces
guerres civiles inventé qui nous empêche
d'aller à l'essentiel et l'essentiel
c'est quand même la cohésion que nous
avons entre nous et la volonté commune
de sortir de la crise et d'offrir à nos
enfants des perspectives
enthousiasmantes en tête en terme de
société et en termes de travail servent
à d'autres questions
revenons si vous le permettez que je
ministre aux questions plus économique
financière et qui penche sur l'évasion
des capitaux comment allez vous empêcher
l'évasion de capitaux demande monsieur
assène son conseiller municipal à
béziers
pensez-vous faire revenir l'argent qui
est partie frauduleusement en suisse se
demande madame muller cadre
administratif à paris on a l'air d'avoir
abandonné les poursuites contre paribas
que pensez-vous faire demande monsieur
de broc comptable à asnières toutes les
toutes les actions qui ont été menées
contre des fraudeurs ou contre des gens
qui cherchent à évadés des capitaux sont
continuer simplement ce n'est pas une
raison pour dresser un bûcher place de
l'hôtel de ville à paris pour telle ou
telle personne
il ya des procédures légales en
démocratie pour permettre aux gens de se
défendre
lorsqu'ils sont accusés par
l'administration d'avoir fraudé ou
d'avoir évadés des capitaux et s'ils
sont condamnés ils sont condamnés à des
amendes et ils doivent les payer
où ils sont mais peuvent être condamnés
à la prison mais ce n'est pas en mettant
cela en exergue tous les jours qu on
recréera en france alors que tant
d'autres
cest sa salsa cha cha rne agité
l'opinion que tant d'autres s'attachent
à énerver les françaises ne serait pas
ainsi que l'on créerait le climat
nécessaire pour l'effort collectif
auquel j'ai fait appel tout à l'heure
monsieur le ministre une question qui
revient souvent également de la part des
téléspectateurs c'est une question de
madame ann arbor à paris qui est
secrétaire de direction en ce qui
concerne la solidarité
on ne parle absolument pas les
fonctionnaires qui ont la sécurité de
l'emploi et passe gentiment à travers
tout la solidarité donc selon madame en
bord n'est pas égal je renvoie madame
aux questions qu'on posait deux
fonctionnaires sur le fait que la lutte
contre les inégalités n'allait pas assez
vite qui pourrait se réunir ensemble et
réfléchir sur ce que sont les inégalités
dans la france d'aujourd'hui notamment
entre ceux qui ont un emploi stable et
ceux qui n'en n'ont pas ceux qui ont un
emploi stable et qu'ils ont et ceux qui
ont un emploi précaire
ceux qui ont des salaires élevés ceux
qui n'en n'ont pas ceux qui ont une
retraite assurée ceux qui n'en n'ont en
moins assuré parce qu'ils n'ont pas
travaillé le nombre d'années utile
autant de sujets de réflexion entre les
français et je suis sûr que si on fait
des émissions en mettant les français en
contact les uns avec les autres
ils progresseront mieux dans la
connaissance des inégalités et ils
comprendront mieux ce que peut-être la
solidarité aujourd'hui parmi les moyens
de lutter contre le chômage il ya la
formation professionnelle mais trop peu
de crédit lui sont consacrés nous dit-on
de nombreux téléspectateurs ont tapé
dans ce sens comment cela se fait-il
à écouter lahav vous me fait de la peine
parce que c'est comme si je suis quand
même à l'origine c'est mon enfance je
suis quand même à l'origine de cette loi
sur la formation professionnelle
c'est moins le manque de crédit qui
m'inquiète que la manière dont elle a
été appliquée cette loi et le gaspillage
des crédits considère qu'avec les sommes
qui sont actuellement dépensés pour la
formation professionnelle
on pourrait faire beaucoup mieux donc ce
n'est pas une question de quantité de
crédits c'est une question de qualité de
dépenses et de revenir à l'esprit de
cette loi qui était fait pour donner à
chaque travailleur à n'importe quel
moment de sa vie les moyens de dominer
ses problèmes de maîtrise et son travail
ou de retrouver un travail
ce ministre une question de monsieur
anaky et militaires à saint-cyr-l'ecole
pourquoi de langage réduction les
horaires de travail pendant bausch dans
la fonction publique donc un mauvais
exemple
je ne comprends pas là nous avons nous à
nous aurons créé dans la fonction dans
las dans le secteur public pris au sens
large 200000 emplois en 18 mois pour
apporter une contribution à la lutte
contre le chômage
quant à la réduction du temps de travail
je répète ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
la réduction du temps de travail en soi
n'a aucun sens dans les dents dans une
france qui doit se battre et qui doit
consacrer toutes ses forces à maintenir
à développer son appareil de production
et à défendre son niveau de vie si par
conséquent nous parlons de réduction du
travail c'est pour partager le travail
je le répète il faut travailler moins
individuellement pour donner la place au
doute et travailler plus collectivement
la france n'a jamais eu besoin autant
aujourd'hui de travailler et de bien
travailler
par conséquent le partage du travail oui
la réduction du travail sans création
d'emplois non est-ce qu'il ya encore
beaucoup d'autres questions svp
peut-être pourrions-nous arrêter quand
même là parce que ille-et-vilaine
dernière une dernière killer des ans et
de monsieur la fiche à paris qui dit que
le ministre l'économie a déclaré
récemment dans une interview que la
situation du franc ne l'empêché pas de
dormir et se préoccupe de l'insomnie du
ministre l'économie et des finances il a
raison de se préoccuper de mes insomnies
car j'en ai souvent et pour de multiples
causes mais c'est vrai que le franc la
défense du français est un élément parmi
d'autres de ma tâche quotidienne et que
par conséquent je m'en préoccupe
simplement le français un instrument de
la politique économique
en ce moment il faut défendre la parité
du franc parce que la compétitivité de
notre économie est bonne et aussi parce
que nous devons à partir de septembre
avec les ministres de l'économie et des
finances des autres pays européens
analyser successivement nos politiques
économiques nos politiques budgétaires
nos politiques monétaires et voir où en
est le système monétaire européen et
j'espère qu'à cette occasion reprendra
les propositions que j'ai faites pour
renforcer le système c'est-à-dire pour
renforcer la cohésion de l'europe est à
cet égard les événements de ces derniers
jours qui ont suscité une crise au sein
de l'europe avec une issue positive pour
les prix agricoles devrait être un
révélateur
je n'ai pas eu l'occasion de le dire
dans cette émission je voudrais le dire
en un mot mais c'est ma conviction
profonde
l'europe ce n'est pas simplement un
idéal mais c'est aussi une nécessité
c'est un idéal pour tous ceux d'entre
vous et dont moi qui ont connu l'avant
guerre le fascisme la guerre plus jamais
ça entre des pays européens mais c'est
aussi une nécessité
aucun pays européen fut-il le plus
puissant ne pourra s'en sortir seul face
à ces deux grandes puissances
économiques que sont les états unis et
l'amérique dans son ensemble le japon
avec tous les pays du pacifique de
l'autre l'unité européenne c'est une
condition de notre survie
voilà pourquoi en dépit de toutes les
difficultés nous proposons sans arrêt
des solutions le président de la
république a proposé un programme de
relance moi même j'ai proposé l'europe à
géométrie variable pour permettre
d'avancer à 6 soit 7 là où on pouvait
avancer l'europe ce n'est pas simplement
un idéal je vous dis c'est une nécessité
et les français ils songent pas assez
ils sont trop repliés sur eux mêmes
il faut qu'ils comprennent que cette
dimension européenne est liée à leur
propre destin celui ci est ce que vous
souhaitez avoir une minute pour conclure
ou est-ce que vous estimez que c'est
notre message final
non je voudrais quand même huit minutes
pour donner les enjeux de votre
politique est expliqué ce vers quoi vous
le conduira france non je crois que ce
que j'ai à dire se résume en trois mots
la patience la solidarité et l'effort la
patience parce que en économie comme en
agriculture rien arrive vite ni ni seul
par conséquent les mois qui viennent
seront difficiles et les journalistes
auront des mauvaises nouvelles qu'aux
l'on pourra parce que c'est la loi de
l'information monté en épingle
ces mauvaises nouvelles je ne me
décourage pas elle ne décourage pas le
gouvernement
ce qu'il faut c'est investir c'est à
dire nous doter d'un appareil de
production bien meilleure mais investir
on en aura les résultats que dans trois
quatre ans d'où la nécessité du plan
ce qu'il faut c'est donner du travail
aux plus de gens possible ce qu'il faut
c'est que dans l'entreprise il y est un
climat qui permette à tout le monde
d'apporter sa pierre pour une meilleure
prospérité une meilleure productivité la
solidarité
encore une fois si les politiques
précédentes ont échoué
c'est parce que le langage d'austérité
était un langage à sens unique
que signifie le langage de rigueur pour
celui qui à 2500 francs par mois pour
vivre
nous avons fait un effort pour cela pour
leur montrer qu'il faisait partie de la
communauté nationale à leur tour
maintenant ils peuvent accéder aux
responsabilités me comprendre les enjeux
il y à du pain blanc pour tout le monde
mais il doit y avoir aussi du pain noir
pour tout le monde
et enfin le troisième élément l'effort
la solidarité doit être le socle sur la
base duquel doit être construit l'effort
national
je dis souvent dans une formule qui
n'est pas peut-être du meilleur goût
l'heure n'est pas à la cueillette des
cerises je veux dire par là que le
moment est devenu de planter des arbres
qui seront les fruits pour nos enfants
le moment est venu de doter notre
économie des moyens de répondre à un
défi qui est peut-être sans doute
beaucoup plus important et beaucoup plus
pernicieux que celui du lendemain de la
hier on aurait pu penser après 30 ans
d'efforts et de travail car on a
beaucoup travaillé pendant 30 ans en
france ou de république on aurait pu
penser que l'heure est venue comme
disait monsieur giscard d'estaing de la
croissance 12 de la société
postindustrielle eh bien pas du tout de
nouveaux défis nous assaillent une
nouvelle révolution industrielle des
compétiteurs acharnés de la
déstabilisation militaire ou sociales
qui nous oblige à nous défendre
tout cela c'est une période rude moi je
la trouve plutôt stimulante mais ne sera
gagné que si l'on retient bien ces trois
mots patience solidarité et fort merci
monsieur le ministre d'avoir inauguré
cette première émission l'heure de
vérité prochain rendez vous le 10 juin
avec georges marchais et le 22 24 juin
avec jacques chirac bonsoir merci
[Musique]